normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is for Mashable Walmart joins the X
Twitter ad boycott this one will sting
The Big Box store joins Apple Disney and
others in ditching X over Elon musk's
comments uh this is uh by Matt bender
and he's he's wrong I think he's lying I
mean it's it's hard to say they like to
say Donald Trump lied and I always ask
well is he wrong or is he lying there's
a difference right I think Matt's lying
because I'm willing to bet in this there
uh yeah here it is here it is just in
time for the holiday shopping season
Walmart decided to stop advertising on
Elon musk's X joining a slew of other
major companies that have fled the
social media platform in recent weeks
second paragraph quote we aren't
advertising on X as we found other
platforms to better reach our customers
a Walmart spokesperson told Reuters
which first reported on the retail claim
Chain's decision to suspend an ad ad
campaigns on the website Walmart's
decision to stop advertising comes after
a must said go off yourself etc etc but
uh the issue is the greater quote from
Walmart was something let let me pull up
Reuters because I got Mashable here on
purpose uh Walmart says it's not
advertising on social platform acts
right but the actual uh quote they say
is has nothing to do with any of this
I'm pretty sure they said we stopped
advertising in October not this is this
is kind of crazy to see a lot of news
outs are reporting this I think there is
a potential that Walmart is trying to
not be involved and and and you know
lower their amount of AD spending but
the the the the original story reporting
this Walmart said they slowed down their
ad spend back in October it has nothing
to do with what Elon said now it's being
reported by these organizations that
it's that it's you know Walmart joining
the ad boycott now either way a lot of
money is being lost by X and one of the
interesting things actually I I just
pulled up threads for the previous
segment and one of the first things that
is suggested to me I don't follow Hank
Green but it's Hank Green he said
numbers for the Curious in the last 30
30 days Tik Tok views 37 million Tik
Tock rev share
$3,600 RPM is 10 cents YouTube shorts
views $41 million YouTube shorts rev
$4,400 41 million views 41 million views
you said dollars oh no yeah sorry sorry
41 million views
$4,400 Real's views uh doesn't report
minimum is 13 million his share was
$988 for a 7 Cent RPM
that's interesting in how uh you make
literally no money no money on these
platforms for all of these views that's
kind of crazy that on Tik Tok you get 37
million views you get wow you're getting
$3,600 you have to be one of the most
famous people to make a living Hank
Green is one of like the biggest social
media influencers and he's only making
3,600 a month off Tik Tok okay combine
them all and he's going to be making
what like 150k a year being the one of
the most famous personalities there's
almost no point in doing any of those
posts it's all just being whittel down
the crazy thing is when you look at X
and the ad boycott I'm wondering how
this will impact how much money people
are all are already getting because the
rates there are super low too I get like
200 million impressions on my on my
profile I get about 5,500 per month from
the from the ad share deal now it's
probably going to go to nothing cuz
what's going on yeah as more people
become influencers too like every human
pretty much has a camera and can as
their side job make a video about what
they do with their main job at the very
least that the ad Revenue I don't think
ad Revenue models are the way to go I
think it's super chats and direct
subscriptions plus then the The
Advertiser can't pull the rug on your
entire business model do you think that
this data will become public enough to
deter gen Z like this is what genen Z
wants to do with their lives most of
them want to be an influencer or they
talk about wanting to be you know social
media personality this is regularly
something they report if is this sort of
like when everyone wants to be an actor
and then at a certain point I mean I'm
sure you experien two people are like
but are you actually going to support
yourself doing that only a couple people
make it big like at what point do people
realize this idea that social media is
the only way like this influencer
pathway is it going to become less
romantic for the youngest
generation hopefully soon because like
if you make internet videos but you do
nothing with your life they're not going
to be very interesting videos but if
you're a mechanic and you make in
Internet videos and you rope in the
mechanics into that it becomes very
interesting so they're synergistic you
don't want to like everyone on my
opinion should have the opportunity to
become an internet video star and and
you should highlight the cool things you
do in your life you could you could make
a YouTube channel where you personally
put things in boxes wrap those boxes and
then call it unboxing presence Channel
and you literally just film yourself
slowly un wrapping a box I'm I'm I'm not
I'm not even J alterate career ladies
and gentlemen no people love this stuff
so you've got viral videos of people
opening like Pokemon cards it doesn't
matter people just want to see what's
inside it's the weirdest thing so you
don't need to be interesting at all you
just need to make content and then
hypnotize people you know what I really
love I love the uh like the hydraulic
press Channel yeah me too I watch a lot
of that now there's like 12 of them then
there's the uh uh uh the Red Hot Nickel
ball y get a lot yeah there's like now
there's like 12 of them and uh I have I
have a really good idea idea that I
wanted to do but you know it's very
dangerous I want to electrocute things
I'm like you know how many volts and
amps or whatever until a teddy bear
bursts in flame but you know there's
someone else who be like yeah I do want
to click on that video I want to know
how many volts it takes I know and you
know my idea was what you do it live and
then every viewer like increases the
voltage by a certain number especially
when water's involved like watching
electricity go through water is
fascinating see there you go but that's
the question and then you get like
20,000 people watching and then like the
energy level is you know going up that'd
be fun right yeah I think there's a lot
of things it's not that I'm against
people making stuff obviously and
putting it on the internet I I'm for it
I just want that to be clear it's just
at a certain point does it pay out the
way people think it's going to and is
this a long-term sustainable career
because I think that's why you need the
influencer ecosystem between all of the
platforms not one platform really
generates enough revenue for a
medium-sized person to austain
themselves is what it sounds like to me
and I don't know yeah definitely not to
sustain but like Ian was saying earlier
like it could be a side hustle I feel
like a lot of people have multiple jobs
these days anyway Biden economy um so
you know just filming your job dayto day
I think people can put that kind of
content out there and it's pretty easy
how many people how many people have
tried doing the I'm going to drive an
Uber and film it and put the videos of
conversations on the internet I've heard
that idea 8,000 times and I'm like yeah
yeah yeah get in
line let you do that they do record some
cars do record whatever's happening
right I'm pretty sure they do you just
got to tell people it's like hey like
when they get in your car and be like
hey do you mind if I film and then put
the thing on my YouTube channel and some
if someone says no like okay and then
you don't M but Uber is a bad job anyway
I feel bad for Uber drivers you cannot
make a living doing that it destroys
your car no costs more to drive your car
yeah when I get a ride from the airport
to here and it's a 100 bucks I'm like
what is that like 60 40 of it goes to
the driver what is crazy and that's all
that's that's going to cover gas and the
wear on the car
yeah and they just spent two and a half
hours driving me like what in the heck
yeah I was reading like in New York that
uh Uber doesn't pay enough to cover the
cost of the wear and tear on the car and
gas but people don't realize wear and
tear so they're like all right yeah made
60 bucks and it's like by the end of the
month that money you're going to be
negative because your car is going to
break and then you have no job I wish we
still had taxis I miss taxis those are
great they still exist you know but good
luck yeah they they've been protesting
quite a bit mhm cuz they got screwed
over by New York but but but anyway man
social media is a wild thing and I'm
kind of feeling like if we do move into
this AI automated future where all work
is is just being nightmare yeah just
cars drive themselves I'm seeing more
videos pop up on Instagram of just you
know like we've automated this job and
that job and you've got all the
self-driving cars now the only job
you're going to have is competing with
each other to get eyeballs and then
humans are going to become more insane
than they already are cuz already if
we're looking at you need 30 7 million
views to make three grand imagine these
psychotic behaviors people will adopt to
to try and make this work yeah they're
going to they're going to I don't know
develop U very serious personality
disorders but that's got to be bad for
it's got to be bad do they develop them
or do the people who are prone to those
personality stores to drop do they want
to be online doing these things is it
sort of like a natural it's a MOS flame
I think this is what wokeness comes from
mhm people are on online and they're
trying to find ways to hit the algorithm
and the algorithms are leading Lemmings
off a cliff but what that makes me think
is like the market tends to adjust and
adopt for what is good and what makes
sense for society I think in general
Maybe not maybe it just leads towards
whatever is most addictive but if the
thing is bringing no value but adding
psychosis to the system I would imagine
that the market would weed it out why
what if we can't tell it's psychosis
because we're so used to it because we
consume so much of this content that we
can't tell the difference between what's
normal and what's not anymore that's a
good point we're there we're absolutely
there so if every Everybody believes
something because everyone's sharing it
I mean we can see the beginnings of this
with the Covington Catholic kids
everybody sees the video they assume
it's true they just said this kid got
that guy's face and then uhoh a two-hour
live stream was uncovered showing
actually it was the other way around
well I was just looking up the uh what
you said like that Walmart had pulled
the ads in October and I found it but I
had to dig deep into Google because even
though that was how they initially
reported x uh the Joe baronage I can't
say his name head of operations at X
said that W Walmart started pulling its
advertising it hasn't advertised since
October so the narrative that is being
spun to the top of Google is actually
different from the way it was originally
reported they decided what was coming
out they shifting reality and I think
that's been the best part of X honestly
like as a user we can fact check these
people in real time now journalists have
just been able to push their narratives
for decades and we haven't been able to
you know dig and actually find it for
ourselves a lot of people don't have the
time or the willingness to do that so
act slapping a community note on
something like this I think is super
beneficial yeah yeah there's a couple
ways to look at it it could be that
Walmart was the first to boycott and no
one reported it so if they're reporting
Trend Setters Walmart yeah I mean if
they're saying Walmart has just joined
no no no no because they stopped
advertising a long time ago or it's
completely unrelated but I'll tell you
what what what proves it's all fake I'm
going to prove to you right now you live
in a fake World likely just being
perpetual ated by the Deep State because
money is fake Fiat currencies here's a
story from India what was it Indian
Express there you go the Indian Express
basan of Journalism says X Twitter has
higher organic traffic but lower ad
Revenue than Facebook and Instagram Elon
Musk he posted this and you can see
Twitter's s uh uh SE trffic
650.000 paid traffic is 1.1 th000 almost
none paid traffic price
14.3k you can look at Instagram they
have 100,000 in paid traffic and
Facebook has 78,000 in paid traffic with
even less views so not only does Twitter
have way more traffic way less of it is
paid
traffic so this means with advertisers
pulling off of X or to give credit to
the leftists who are saying Walmart's
jumping Walmart's saying we're
doing better on other platforms I don't
buy it I don't believe they are I've
also done advertising on these other
platforms and I believe believe that
most of it is fake a bot will watch your
ad and then they'll say well we assume
it's real cuz how are they supposed to
know I knew these dudes who were
starting a company that's that's their
whole job uh the whole company premise
was to to you you they would operate in
between the company and the social media
platform so company would say we want to
do an ad then social media company would
say okay they would go in the middle and
track all of the link clicks to see how
many were fake and how many were not and
I think they were telling me like around
half or more is fake half so that means
when you spend 10 bucks you think you're
getting a certain amount of views you're
getting half that mhm it's all fake so
now we know that Twitter is the best why
aren't they why isn't anybody spending
money there why spend money on Facebook
when we all know Facebook isn't giving
you the same return because Elon Musk
bad Tim we can't be anywhere near him
him and that orange guy yep I think the
targeted ads are enticing with Facebook
you they track people so well you can be
like I'm looking for 27-year-old males
that wear red hats that live near
Philadelphia that are awake between the
hours of 4: and 900 p.m. and like I
don't know Twitter can can offer that
kind of targeted ad Revenue I mean even
if half of them are Bots that's still
really really good
targeting but it actually means that the
price is twice as high because you're
getting half as many views it's more
than twice Oh you mean to to advertise
to targeted audiences is like eight
bucks for thousand views whereas on
targeted is like $150 for a th000 views
but is that what your question was no
what I'm saying is like if I were to
spend whatever amount of money because I
think that's going to get me a th000
views but actually it's getting me 500
the price per view is much higher than
their advertis they're reporting to you
it's 1,000 views and they just not
telling you that the other half are fake
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net